こんにちははじめしゃちょーと
YouTubeどうもHIKAKINです
HIKAKINさんようこそ
我が家親分僕ですね
最近やばい
能力身につけてしまいましてもうこれは
危ないですもうマジねはい
怖いねちょっと早速親分でやっちゃってみ
ていいですかいいよいいですか
[音楽]
起き上がりなさい
はい皆さん今日ですねこれもう
HIKAKINさんの
元々HIKAKINさんの体の中に入って
いたHikakinさんを今一時的に
取り出しまして空っぽのHIKAKIN
さんになってしまいました
俺が手に入れた能力は人の中身を空っぽに
し自分を憑依させる能力です今これはもう
僕の指示通りに動くHIKAKIN人魚に
なってしまったので自由に操れる
Hikakinさんを使ってオレンジに
いるやつらにドッキリ仕掛けていきたいと
思います何でもできるんですパンツして
ください
これがHIKAKINのこと凄さです
もう
たまに自我があるので自動で動くことも
ありますが基本的には僕が言ったことを
確実に遂行するヒカキンロボになって
しまいました
もともといたHIKAKINさんの残留
印象が残ってるので心の声がたまに聞こえ
てきますがそのうちなくなると思います
今日はよろしくお願いします
ちゃんと挨拶もできるそもそもうちに
HIKAKINさんがいること自体きっと
みんなびっくりすると思うのでその
ヒカキンさんがありえない行動するって
ことが今できるようになったわけなんです
よ親分すごいこう
礼儀正しいというかすごいしっかりしてる
んですけども今回の親分は親分じゃない
ですほぼ
不思議な映像が撮れることでしょう早速
HIKAKINさんの見た目をしたこの
これを
設置したいと思いますついて来い
その後ヒカキンロボははじめ社長から
あらゆる悪さを学んだ人の銅像の上に
座る悪さ
キャッチボールをしている時に
投げてもらったボールを
適当にぶん殴る
椅子に座ろうとしている人の椅子を引いて
転がせる
トイレに駆け込んだ主人を
外から
閉じ込めてそのまま24時間出さない悪さ
そうヒカキンロボは
史上最強に悪い男に仕上がってしまったの
であっ
た
素晴らしい敵だ後輩が家に来るので全部
止めなさい
[拍手]
これで後輩を困らせる
[音楽]
やばいことしてるんだHikakinさん
をこんなこと使っちゃいいんか用意して
もらってるので今日はどこでやってもらい
ましょう
[音楽]
はじめまして
失礼します
こっちじゃない
[音楽]
んだろう
勢いよく入っちゃいましょ勢いが大事です
から最初の
衝撃を与えたいみんなに
[音楽]
全員睨みつけるんだ
飲まなかった
[音楽]
近くで初めて
そのまま真ん中の机にどんどん
座っちゃいましょう
[音楽]
みんな食べてないのでご飯食べなさいって
言ってください
[音楽]
やめ
これでちょっと様子見ましょうか
これ食べたいわけじゃないよね動き
ましょうかそろそろたなっちがお肉食べて
そうなのでマジックで7つのほっぺに肉
って書きましょう
油性っぽかったんだけど
[音楽]
良平先生何食べてる
ちょっと何食べてるか見たいので親分
ちょっと洋平先生のご飯を奪ってください
あーなるほどなるほどじゃあそのまま親分
お稲荷さん食べちゃいましょう
[音楽]
全然いいですけど次はそのオレンジ
ジュースをふってください
[拍手]
[音楽]
ありがとうございますよく混ざって
喜んでることでしょうまたどのほっぺに
骨って書きましょうちょっと彼細いので
これででもちょっとわかるかもしれない
ヒントあるか
[音楽]
骨って
最後はまたぞうのご飯と
七つのお弁当を取って
逃げるんだ
[音楽]
俺の
は
[音楽]
本当にそう思ってるから
これ
ロッカーのね
[音楽]
こちら
ターゲットはこれだ
これだ
この車を
破壊しなさいはい
[音楽]
というわけでご覧ください再帰完了です
早速指令を与えていきたいと思います
[音楽]
まずは
タイヤをキックだ
やっぱり皆さん勘違いしないでください
HIKAKINさんやってるわけではなく
僕の意思としてやっているので
欠席はないです次はちょっと
鍵かかってるので鍵を解除した後に
ボンネットあたりから車を
揺らすんだ
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
ターゲットソースを呼んでみましょうか
ターゲット呼んでくるのでまたちょっと
タイヤとか車周りを
蹴ったりバンバンしたりしててください
[音楽]
運転できます
ちょっと
[音楽]
監視カメラ見て
やばいやばいやばいやばい
[音楽]
これおかしい
じゃんめちゃめちゃ
叩いてるよ
結構強くやってるよやばいやばいやばい
やばい
待って光ってる待って本当にやってる
やばいやばい
[拍手]
[笑い]
[音楽]
お
疲れ
いやーいい働きぶりでした
のでちょっと解除しようかな
[音楽]
俺なんか
迷惑YouTuberになった夢を見てい
たな親分ですか
[音楽]
楽しい夢を見ていただき本当ですかずっと
寝てましたけど
憑依されてたんですかね
あのゲームよかったらちょっと一緒にやり
ませんかあれだなはい再現作りましたと
いうゲーム
憑依といえばこのゲームなのでちょっと
是非遊んでみましょうはいというわけで
約3年間かけて作った髪流し自慢ちょっと
HIKAKINさんと遊んでいきたいと
思います
また今日痩せてしまった簡単に言えば神
から逃げるっていうゲームなんですよ
怖いね神になってボコボコにするのも
楽しいんですけどもせっかく
HIKAKINさんといるので2人で人と
してちょっと逃げて遊びましょう
逃げる側か
逃げましょう僕ねさっきちょっと
ヒカキンゲームズで初見でプレイさせて
もらって結構いい動きしてたんでまあ
勝てると思いますよ心強いです期待して
おります概要欄にありますので是非
ヒカキンゲームズを見てくださいぜひ行き
ますよはい本当にざっくりその
敵から結果を解除するって感じで全部解除
したら逃げれます脱出口みたいなはい7個
あるんだよね7個ありますね
今日も猫背で可愛いね
ホーミングアップでパンチしてるよし
じゃあ一番近いところ
親分のキャラ歩き方可愛い
これやばいやばい
これ電車とかでやってたらさ
やばいね結構声出ちゃう俺来てるやばい
痛い
皆さん人がね周りにいる時は叫ばないよう
にしましょうね
右をやっぱ結構序盤からピンチ
大丈夫か
なみんなで結界一緒に1箇所やった方が
早いんだよねそうですねただまとめてやら
れちゃうこともあるので
難しいんですよね
ちょっと親分回復してください
偽物とかいるんですよなんか化けてくんだ
よ神がこれ神が俺に化けてますねこれ
いやー気づけないからね下手すると
よしもう大丈夫そうじゃないですかすい
ません俺めちゃめちゃ誰かが電話かかっ
てる今かけてくんねんけどこれどうしよう
どうしたの
大丈夫かはじめしゃちょーの動画撮ってる
んだけど
はい
今いきなりかかってきたよ
もうめっちゃあとちょっとじゃんあと2個
です
ちょっと見られてるなえっと
行くよ
ありがとうございます俺もやべえじゃん
本当だ
食べてくださいマジで
結局
スキルって連続でできないのかちょっと
ちょっと待って
俺がいる用意されている
うわあナイフ持ってるこの人
助けてくださいバイブが追いかけられてる
間に俺解除します
あと1個だ
蒸気が濃くなってきました
よしラスト
勝てるぞやばい1人やられてる
まずいなあはじめしゃちょーどこにいんだ
僕今えっと
脱出口のすぐ近くにいて解除されたらすぐ
逃げようと思ってます
素晴らしいあそっかそっか元々から脱出口
ってあるんだOK
言っちゃったよ
先に出るぜ
よっしゃーうわー世界が赤くなった
助けて
頑張れ
助けてあげたいこの人やばいか
走り方可愛いなぁ
助ける早い早い早い
大丈夫ですか
やばいやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
助けてあげた俺
これで最悪あれもう一人やられてる
あれもうやられた
まだ大丈夫ですちょっと生きてます
え2人やられてる
[音楽]
大丈夫ですか
HIKAKINさんの髪流してしまう遊ん
でみたんですけれどもやっぱちょっとその
ホラー要素もありつつ美少女もこう
たくさんいるっていうちょっと本当に僕が
好きなゲームを盛り込んだような内容にも
なってるのでぜひゲームを楽しいので遊ん
でみてください
概要欄からダウンロードして遊んで
くださいそのためにね車蹴ったんでね
間違いないはいありがとうございます
神が
哲也に
憑依した時もありましたけれども
緊急事態系かなと思ってしばらく無視して
たのよ
[音楽]
やったーとか言ってたけどそれもじゃあ
楽しみにそうですね
それで負けたんで
許さねえぞ
ぜひ神流します遊んでみてくださいじゃあ
[音楽]